Caroline Aghajanian: Taylor
Guitars was founded by
Bob Taylor and Kurt Listug in 1974.
That's fairly new considering
some of its competitors,
like Gibson or Martin Guitars.
Today, big music names like Taylor Swift,
Jason Mraz, and Zac Brown
strum to the tune of a Taylor guitar.
Hi, I'm Caroline,
and today we're taking you inside
the Taylor Guitars factory,
where they combine
craftsmanship and automation
to produce hundreds of guitars a day.
The company has two factories.
One in El Cajon, California,
and the other in Tecate, Mexico.
In 2017, they made over
$102 million in revenue.
Chris Wellons: Currently, we're
producing over 720 guitars
a day between both of our factories.
We're slated to build over
160,000 guitars this year alone.
Caroline: Taylor guitars
range between $350
to more than $9,000.
So, why such a high price tag?
Well, a big factor is the type of wood
and materials used.
They currently have over
35 species of wood in house
to choose from.
Their factory in El Cajon
makes their guitars out of all solid wood
instead of laminate construction.
Some models require advanced
woodworking techniques
or greater decorated detail work,
which can also increase the price.
If the guitar is well maintained,
the sound will continue to improve
as the guitar's wood ages,
making it sound richer and more resonant.
The factory runs 24 hours a day,
five days a week.
They have over 900
employees building guitars
with the help of some robotics.
Chris: We blend robotics and automation
with lots of handwork.
I think automation is
great, first and foremost.
It's very important to
continue to advance the factory
and move it forward.
The one thing we pride ourselves on
is we've never replaced an
employee with any automation.
We've always deployed those
employees into other areas
or into the same department,
which has allowed us to increase
our production capacities.